alrighty folks almost exactly a year ago
i went through some of my most viral
moments
on the interwebs as expected there were
many clips left on the editing room
floor so
we've decided to make volume two the
revenge
in this video we're gonna watch another
handful of my best most shocking
moments before we start i must remind
you this video is sponsored by giant
partners
stay for the ad a little later and i'll
tell you a little story of the daily
wire and how we got started
if you are going to dictate to me that i
am supposed to pretend i'm supposed to
pretend
that men are women and women are men no
okay but you're still saying these kids
should like not be accepted because they
don't really fit in
either place they can't just like i'm
saying that the boy scouts have a
standard you must be a biological boy to
be a boy scout you have to be a boy to
be a boy scout
in the name boy scouts
i will ask you how old you are okay
because you're young enough that it's
probably not insulting to ask you
so i'm 22 so i'm probably naive right no
why aren't you 60
why aren't you 60.
why can't you identify as 60 why what
what is the problem with you identifying
as 60.
you're right age is significantly less
important than gender the problem with
this entire line of questioning that
she's pursuing here
is that she refuses to define her terms
she and this is the problem with the
entire quote unquote transgender rights
movement is a complete refusal to
define terms and and what exactly terms
mean what does she mean by sex what does
she mean by gender
and this is why when i say age right
which is a definition we all share
just the way we used to share a
definition of sex she has no comeback
because she understands
you can't arbitrarily redefine your age
ironically though the left will suggest
that race is a social construct but you
can't arbitrarily redefine your race or
this came up in the case of rachel
dolezal for example who was a white lady
who identified as a black woman
and everybody laughed but if you're a
man who identifies as a woman we're all
supposed to say oh i guess you are a
woman now
based on some bizarre gender theory that
is completely non-rooted
in biology if you can find an objective
test telling me
whether a a transgender person is a
member of the sex to which they claim
membership
then we can start talking but if the
idea is that a simple sense of self
redefinition changes the objective way
everybody else
is supposed to see your sex that's
absurdity on his face which is the point
about age
this was at a particularly small college
it was a very tiny college
i think there are maybe 6 700 people in
the room this is very early on
in the in the sort of shapiro going on
college campuses tour you can tell by
the uh by the fact that i've lost a
little bit of weight since then
how are you doing i'm pretty good how
are you doing i'm doing okay a little
chilly but it's november right it seems
like a lot of security for
no protesters
let him speak spanish
how are you nice to meet you pleasure to
meet you
you know that you weren't registered
whatever for the group didn't register
for an event
they have certain things not allowed you
know
well i mean yf did inform you that i was
coming as a speaker as a
as a person sitting in the audience as
well as a member of christina huff
summers team so
i'm not sure what other standards are
necessary i'm also wondering exactly why
it's so necessary to keep me personally
out
we're just following protoculture uh
well why is your protocol to keep me
specifically out what country protocol
soviet union or united states do you
want to step over here to decide
well i'm happy to do it right here if
you'd if you'd like i mean i don't think
this needs to be private the bottom line
is it's a private property okay then
it wasn't proper procedures weren't
followed and you're not going to be
allowed
so i might understand that if i take
three steps forward do all the time to
have me arrested
if you create a problem and you will not
you know leave the campus yes
clearly you have great security i'm glad
in a city that has some 4 000 shootings
to this date you have 30 members of
security just for a 59165 jewish guy
maybe a mild allocation of resources
well
okay well if that's where we're going to
do this and we'll just do the event
elsewhere folks so follow us
so this is a crazy evening okay so
basically
depaul had announced that they were
going to ban me from campus that i was
not allowed on campus and
they'd done this because so many people
on the left said that they were going to
basically riot and create a problem
so yaf instead booked christina summers
the plan was christina was going to
speak and then
she was going to end up introducing me
and welcoming me on to the stage and it
was going to be
advertised as a christina hoff summer's
event they registered me as a member of
christina's security detail as a member
of the audience and as a potential
speaker
the administration made clear they did
not want me on campus uh this large
gentleman was
was not just threatening me uh behind
him was the sheriff of cook county
they'd actually brought the sheriff of
cook county which is chicago
uh out there ready to arrest me ready to
effectuate the arrest if i had taken
several steps for one of the reasons i
think that he kept saying could you edge
over to the side here is because the
minute i stepped off that sidewalk i was
then on
non-public depaul property at which
point they probably would have arrested
me was my understanding which is why i
say
no let's stay here like here's a good
place and i did think to myself at this
point is it worth it getting arrested
and then i thought do i really want to
spend
overnight in jail in cook county
no no that seems like a very bad idea
so instead what we did is we tried to
find a local theater that was in walking
distance it was like a tiny little hole
in the wall theater
uh that was maybe four blocks from here
we walked directly over there we led
sort of a pied piper
line out the door uh several hundred
students i called her on the phone i was
like okay christina so here's what we're
gonna do so christina
uh got out and uh rode over there and
all these students showed up and we
proceeded to do
uh the show with christina speaking and
i spoke as well take took some questions
it was a really wild event and a very
kind of bizarre evening for sure
how can you argue that racism is not
a driving factor in income inequality
because it has nothing to do with race
and everything to do with culture and
when you have a culture that doesn't
and when and when you know what explain
to me you explain to me why black kids
aren't graduating high school
explain that one to me explain to me why
black kids are shooting each other in
rates
significantly higher than whites are
shooting each other explain me why 13
of the population is responsible for 50
of the murder explain to me
why the why the number of blacks black
kids in prison not for
innocent reasons not for walking down
the street and getting pulled into a
prison is so high
explain if it has nothing to do with
culture explain to me why the single
motherhood rate in the black community
jumped from 20 to 70 percent in the same
course of time that the civil rights
movement
has made such tremendous strides is
america more racist now than it was in
1960 and if it is please explain to me
how that happened
we're doing these debates uh over at 770
ktth
this is when i was hosting a local show
in seattle so for a while there
2013 through 2015 i believe
i actually hosted six hours of radio a
day so i'd do three hours in the morning
in la and then i would do three hours in
the afternoon in seattle and i would
remote it in but i would fly up to
seattle
once a month for a week or so and i
would do the show from there and
once every couple of months we'd do a
debate so i did a debate on minimum wage
with shama salwan who was on the city
council and then i did
this debate which involved a woman from
local naacp that's the one on the left
and then the fellow who is next to her
is a guy who's writing for the seattle
stranger what set me off here was
the reaction when i said that culture
has something to do with how people act
which of course is true
and you can see the woman and the
gentleman on my right
both react with astonishment it has to
be race it has to just be discrimination
pure and simple it's so
clearly and obviously true that this has
nothing to do with genetics and nothing
to do with skin color and everything to
do
with individual decision making that has
really nasty impact on how people live
and then i lay out all the different
sort of disparate statistics and make
the point that a lot of these problems
have gotten a significant amount worse
since the civil rights act now there is
no good response to this particular
argument particularly the changes with
regard to single motherhood
why is it that single motherhood which
obviously has downstream effects in
terms of poverty and in terms of
education and in terms of crime has
risen so dramatically in the black
community
at the same time that racism has gotten
a lot better in the united states there
is no great response to it
i understand why people would be
warier of police officers given the fact
that many police officers are going to
react to disproportionate crime
statistics with stereotypes
i understand that there is this idea out
there that every person who is born
white is born privileged
and i don't think that that is accurate
just i don't think that every person who
is born black
is born into a horrible situation i
think that we're all
born individuals and if we can start
seeing each other that way we'll all be
a lot better off
i agree okay well i do remember that
over the course of the the evening
we went from you know very stern
disagreement to a lot more agreement and
i will say that
maybe that had something to do with the
persuasive tactics but it's interesting
that she says that she agrees that
people should be treated individually
that is precisely the opposite
of what the critical race theorists say
now i'm basically just citing
pure martin luther king here and at this
time
even seven eight years ago this was seen
as a fairly unifying perspective you can
see things would have changed now i
doubt that the people on the stage
if they have the same perspective good
for them but i think that if you found
people to debate me on race today
that simple statement that people should
be treated as individuals would be a
controversial one today
we'll get to more of me reviewing some
of my most viral moments in just a
moment first
how dailywire got started so not only
did we start in a pool house we started
with a dream but that dream
was backed by an actual vision and that
vision was backed by marketing
marketing marketing marketing was the
name of the game and that's how daley
wire became a global force well
you want to build your company marketing
matters to you too my friends over at
giant partners have marketing secrets
that have been transforming businesses
for over
20 years they're america's number one
data-driven marketing agency
giant partners operates in the business
to business space offering a variety of
business marketing solutions
such as database marketing brand
development web design seo lead
generation digital marketing services
as well as ad placement that's just to
name a few giant partners has worked
with countless fortune 500 companies
now they're offering their secret tips
to you and your business giant partners
is hosting a free
live webinar where they will be sharing
their marketing secrets about how to
transform your business in 2021 and
beyond
marketing is the name of the game
knowing how to market it's something
giant partners does
really really well you need their input
make sure to rsvp to reserve your spot
because space is limited head on over to
giant partners.com and get your business
set up today and rsvp it's their free
webinar at the link
below they'll be giving away some cool
free stuff as well but only if you're
rsvp so don't wait
rsvp today at the link below the idea
that all of these socialized medicine
countries have it so much better than we
do particularly in terms of cancer care
is a joke
we are still number one in terms of
five-year cancer survival rate here in
the united states
sure there are different areas where we
excel
but ben honestly you're cherry picking
there at one particular area that we're
good
overall we're number 37 that is
not a good result the standard of care
is the entire question when it comes to
single-payer health care but the fact is
that rationing is mandated as soon as
you start having the government run the
health care system and decide what level
of care people get they don't care about
me they don't know my child's name they
don't
know my name all they know is how much i
cost
okay so this was a really entertaining
debate with chang what was weird about
this debate is that
number one in the run-up there was all
sorts of of press about it
and then we packed the stadium actually
to move us to a different room because
how many people showed up was like they
were expecting a thousand people three
thousand people
showed up and backstage i was saying to
chunk like it'll be rock and sock and
robots and
and we'll have a good time and then he
started to sort of get agitated during
the debate and upset during the debate
and it turned into a healthcare debate
which was very strange the moderator
instead of actually letting us cover a
wide variety of issues just decided to
focus in
on healthcare because that's always an
area where people on the left think they
have
an advantage and a lot of the talk here
ended up basically being about
healthcare and campaign finance
reform honestly i thought it was an
enjoyable debate i thought it was pretty
cordial
uh but you know there were obviously
some moments that went viral
actually the moment that went most viral
was the the moment where he was talking
about campaign finance reform and the
evils of money and politics and i was
like well yeah dude you're funded by
a billionaire and you take a bunch of
money from advertisers
and for a guy who doesn't like
capitalism and outside funding very much
you seem like
you're kind of okay with it you had an
investor right when you started tyt
you were given four million dollars by
buddy romer to start tyt that's great
that's the way business should work
right
but that money had didn't come from a
bunch of poor people buying hamburgers
it came from
a very very wealthy guy who gave you
money to create a business a lot of
people want to patronize
if money was speech well then if you go
to a hooker
and you say oh no officer i was just
talking to her
okay money is not speech again i
ask you buddy romer gave you four
million dollars to start tyt
what did he expect in return should he
not have given you money was the money
not speech it was just money after all
it's like a hooker i assume so are you
the prostitute how did this work
you are a corporation tyt it's a
corporation you have 80 employees
i assume that you're not just a greedy
and that you actually would like
to help your
your employees from time to time you
seem to be identifying a higher tax rate
in the 1950s with higher level of growth
so if that's the case why not just tax
everybody at 100 we can have massive
growth from here to eternity that's not
to say that that is the right tax rate
for us today
and so the exercise of finding the right
tax rate
is guys try to follow along
okay it's called logic this is hilarious
if you're uneducated please at least
don't
don't make it obvious you're not giving
me the money it was my money in the
first place
created through voluntary transactions
that i had with others i've not stolen
money from either from anyone
neither have you and the idea that money
has to be forcibly taken from you and
handed to somebody at the bottom end of
the economic spectrum to somehow jog the
economy that may jog mcdonald's but is
not going to jog
all of the creation of the products and
services that make all of our lives much
better today
than they were 30 years ago in terms of
the stuff we have access to come on
yeah this part of the conversation did
not go well for check the crowd i think
going in was pretty
heavily in my favor which i was shocked
by i remember when we when we got to
politicon politicon
is not a right-wing organization and we
assumed that because tyt had really been
hammering that they were going to be
doing this debate
that we'd be outnumbered in terms of the
number of people in the crowd instead it
turned out it's probably two to one
uh in favor of me which is why you can
hear the crowd resonating the way that
it does yeah i actually encouraged the
crowd a couple times like guys just let
it be like
let chang say his piece um but uh you
know it sort of wrapped up and i think
chang felt pretty bad about it
i didn't like spend the next few weeks
talking about how wonderful the debate
was for me
he spent the next few weeks speaking
about how terrible the debate was for
him from what i understand
so mr shapiro my question to you is um
for miss miss dumpston the tying the
news around the campus and writing
messages
that target african-american young
students would you consider that hate
speech and then would you stand next to
her and fight for her
as i said this is the first time hearing
about it honestly but
it really yeah um but but from from
hearing about
maybe because it's local i mean i'm from
l.a but in any case
um i'm more than happy more than happy
to to stand alongside her
and and fight whatever group was
responsible for this not not only more
than happy i mean you're talking about
the alt-right again i was the number one
target of anti-semitic harassment from
the alt-right last year
so i'm more than happy to do all that
and i i think there's one more
distinction that has to be made when we
talk about cases
like like taylor's they're horrific and
the administration is siding with taylor
the administration is doing the right
thing by taylor or trying to do the
right thing
by taylor as they should be and i think
that we need to make a distinction
between cases where the administration
is actively participating in the
suppression of speech in cases in which
the administration is trying to do the
right thing as a
as in order to in order to make people
in order to punish people
for uh application of crime i was asked
to testify by jim jordan
and some other members of the the house
committee here i believe adam carol is
on the side of me here i was asked to
testify
uh on free speech on college campuses
you know a few democrats
showed up and wanted to ask questions i
do remember right after this i actually
went up to taylor dunstan who apparently
had allegedly been targeted by some sort
of hate crime
and i gave her my phone number and i
said if you need help in any way
let me know the fact is when you try and
peg democrats down to exactly what they
are talking about
very often the answer is that they don't
really want to be pegged down this is
why they tend to use mush terms like
systemic racism or white privilege
because it allows them to avoid actual
serious conversations about real issues
that could be taken on
now in politics the goal really should
be about solutions because i don't go to
politicians for empathy i go to
politicians for solutions
but for so many people in politics
they're looking for empathy and so when
they cite things like systemic privilege
or white privilege or systemic racism
what they are really saying is i
understand you i
understand your pain or you don't
understand my pain none of that is
geared toward
solving problems it's really more geared
toward emotional response
alrighty so that was volume two the
revenge
of me going through some of my most
viral moments hope you enjoyed it as
little as i did hope you enjoyed it
as much as i did we will see you here
for volume three return
of the shapiro